you do have strongmen coming back in
Venezuela Ecuador Argentina Nicaragua
but you have other countries like Chile
Colombia Peru Brazil where institutions
seem like they're starting to take hold
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for recent TV
today we're talking with Mary Anastasia
Grady of The Wall Street Journal
editorial board as well as the Americas
columnist Mary thanks for taking time
with us in the 90s there was a real
optimism for economic and political
liberalization in Latin America looking
at the latest the 200 2010 index of
economic freedom Chile is number 10 then
the next country is El Salvador at
number 32 did the liberalization work
did it fail I actually think that what's
happening in Latin America is a kind of
bifurcation of the region the promising
thing about the 90s is they were trying
to get the government out of the economy
but you know these processes are not
linear and it does matter the sequence
that you do them and it also matters if
you do them only halfway so in the case
of a lot of the governments they
privatized industries but they ended up
having no real acknowledgement of the
importance of the rule of law they also
maybe they tried to anchor their
currencies but then they did not do the
thing they did not stop the central bank
from lending to the government I think
what's important to recognize is that
it's a process you do have strongmen
coming back in Venezuela Ecuador
Argentina Nicaragua but you have other
countries like Chile Colombia Peru
Brazil where institutions seem like
they're starting to take hold is there a
particular country
south of the US Mexican border that
would provide a model for the rest of
the region well Chile has done a good
job I mean it it backtracked a little
bit over the last decade but I think
it's done a pretty good job and it has
certainly very admirable institutions
what has it done right
the main thing Chile did was it opened
its market trade opening is that is the
wedge because once you open you have
to compete with the world well let's
talk about a drug-related violence
Colombia's former president Aruba was
praised for drastic crime reduction
there were significant drops in the
poverty and unemployment rates during
his tenure on the other hand he's got a
lot of human rights violations or
charges about that did he do well or did
he do badly I think he did very well I
mean you know you mentioned the human
rights violations I think it was in the
interest of the gorillas who are the
Marxist guerrillas who have been in
Colombia for 50 years to allege human
rights violations in fact I did a lot of
work on that where I what I found was
that there was a law that said if you if
someone comes into the courtroom and
accuses a military leader of a human
rights violation that military leader
must be removed from his post or the
government of Colombia will lose its
funding from the US for that unit of the
military and so that motivated a lot of
charges of human rights violations
basically what a rebate did which really
made a difference in Colombia was that
he went out and gave people protection
in the rural areas within the cities it
was okay but in the rural areas they
were population was very vulnerable now
that he's out of office will that crime
will crime stay at the level it's at or
will it come back up well I think he did
a very good job also of sort of
beheading the the leadership of the FARC
which was really a big part of the
violence and I think what's happened
there is a lot of the business has gone
to countries which don't have so much
emphasis on security
what could the u.s. do to minimize drug
violence along the Mexican border well
the best thing I think would be to lift
the prohibition on drugs I mean all of
the income from drug use in the u.s.
goes directly into the pockets of
criminals the Mexican attorney general
had estimated with me and this goes back
four years that something like ten
billion dollars in cash goes across the
border and right into the pockets of
criminals and Mexico here okay so and
the drug war yeah and the violence in
the same way that
we had prohibition against alcohol in
credit violence yeah if we illegal if we
prohibited Mexican butter there would
probably be battles over that how do you
do that politically in a u.s. climate to
put that message out there that it's not
the same as endorsing drug use or
embracing that lifestyle I think it just
was half of what it is is about saying
what are the costs and benefits of the
current policy what are the costs and
benefits of other policies that we we
might pursue all of this money flowing
to the pockets of criminals immediately
implies corruption I mean it undermines
the institutions and institutions as we
talked about all the time the importance
of institutions in developing economies
but the other thing is I do not think
that the solution to this problem will
come from Washington I think it will
come in the grassroots level I think in
the United States right now there's a
greater and greater awareness on the
part of parents that drugs being illegal
is not the answer I mean for heaven's
sakes drugs are all over prisons if we
can't keep drugs out of prisons how are
we going to keep them out of a free
society so are you suggesting we should
turn the schools into prison they're not
far off in a final question was it a
good thing that Mario Vargas Llosa won
the Nobel Prize for Literature sure yeah
very good I mean he has a lifelong
commitment against dictatorship and I
think that's extremely admirable and
he's been consistent on it I mean he
doesn't back down when it comes to Chile
and he doesn't back down when it comes
to modern-day Venezuela marry Anastasia
O'Grady of the Wall Street Journal thank
you for talking to Reason TV thank you